AS MANY AS 8000 MIGRANTS AND
APPREHENSIONS.
HERE TO REACT IS CHAD WOLF.
THE SENIOR GENERAL SAID THEY
ARE GOING TO NEED HELP FROM THE
PENTAGON.
>> REQUEST FOR ASSISTANCE.
ALL THE RESPONSIBILITIES FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE.
THEY REFUSED TO CALL THIS A
CRISIS, THE WORST NUMBERS WE'VE
SEEN IN THE GENERATION.
THAT IS VERY INTERESTING.
RACHEL: THOSE WHO ARE NOT
DISEASED BY THIS, THEY ARE
GRIPPING FOR MORE CHAOS AND
CRIME.
AND SOCIAL SERVICES, FOR
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
I WANT TO MOVE TO ANOTHER
TOPIC.
>> IT IS IMPORTANT FOR FOLKS TO
REMEMBER WE ARE ON TRACK THIS
FISCAL YEAR WITH 5 OR 6 MONTHS
INTO IT TO ECLIPSE, THE HIGHEST
ON RECORD EVER.
THERE IS NO STRATEGY AT THE
BORDER, THEY TORE DOWN A NUMBER
OF SUCCESSFUL INITIATIVES
DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THE ONLY THING THAT'S KEEPING
THEIR HEAD ABOVE WATER IS TITLE
42 WHICH IS GOING AWAY AS WELL.
ONCE THAT OCCURS, THE CRISIS IN
THE PAST 12 OR 15 MONTHS
BECOMES CATASTROPHIC BECAUSE
THEY ARE UNABLE TO REMOVE
INDIVIDUALS AND YOU SEE A
LARGER NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
SHOWING UP TO CROSS THE BORDER.
RACHEL: WE ARE HEARING ABOUT
RUSSIAN AGENTS IN MEXICO IN
OTHER TROUBLING SITUATIONS IS
WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR US.
MEXICO IS NEUTRAL ON UKRAINE,
MEXICO SAYS THEY ARE
DOWNPLAYING.
LET ME GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS.
FROM MEXICO'S PRESIDENT, HE
SAYS WE DON'T HAVE INFORMATION.
TO SPY ON ANYBODY.
MORE TO BEIJING, TO WASHINGTON,
IT DOESN'T ANSWER THE QUESTION,
RUSSIAN AGENTS WORKING IN
MEXICO AND DOES MEXICO WORK ON
IT?
>> IF YOU WANT TO DO IT
ILLEGALLY, YOU CAN DO IT ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND THAT IS WHY
BORDER PATROL PICKS UP 120
DIFFERENT NATIONALITIES HAVE
FREE YEAR AND THAT IS WHY THEY
ARE PICKING UP UKRAINIANS.
THE IDEA THEY ARE WORKING
INSIDE, SOUTH OF THE BORDER FOR
ANY NUMBER OF REASONS.
A NUMBER OF KNOWN AND SUSPECTED
TERRORISTS DHS IS PICKING UP
THE LAST 12 TO 13 MONTHS IS
INCREASED NUMBERS WE'VE NOT
SEEN BEFORE.
IT IS NO SECRET IF YOU WANT TO
GET ACROSS INTO THE UNITED
STATES YOUR BEST BET IS TO
EMBED YOUR SELF INTO THIS
HISTORIC NUMBER, FLOW OF
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE BORDE